Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and This is going
to be my Constantine Review.
The episode they aired was actually a slightly
different version from the original pilot.
They made a few changes to the cast, all good
things.
I’ll totally explain what’s going on as
I work through best moments.
I will be doing weekly videos for all the
episodes.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet, starting with Top 5 moment,
Number 5 - Ravenscar Psychiatric Hospital
This is the place Constantine admits himself
to after Astra was taken to Hell.
In the comics he’s been in and out of it
more than once, but on the show I don’t
think they’ll send him back.
Or if they do it would be at the end of the
season and then at the beginning of season
2 he’d leave again.
It’s a place they could go back to.
But I don’t think they will.
They changed a few things about the Astra
incident on the show too.
In the comics, Constantine had his own Punk
Rock band called Mucous Membrane in the early
80s.
While they were playing in Newcastle England
they found a girl named Astra who had raised
a demon to get revenge on a group of people
that had been sexually abusing her.
The rest of the story is pretty much what
the show told.
Constantine tried to raise his own demon to
destroy Astra’s demon but he lost control
of it.
The demon killed Astra’s lesser demon and
then killed her, taking her soul to hell.
She’s currently being held hostage by the
Demon Nergal, he’s one of the big inner
circle demons they mentioned.
In the comics, he’s like Constantine’s
Moriarty, his biggest nemesis.
So Nergal is the big bad on the show.
Number 4 - Liv Aberdeen, Jasper Winters and
the Zed Swap
Liv Aberdeen wasn’t from the comics, she
was a new character they created for the show.
NBC and the producers just decided the character
wasn’t working so they reshot some things
from the pilot and during the episode we just
watched.
They added the scene at the end with the woman
drawing all the pictures.
If you couldn’t tell, those were illustrations
from the comics, just a nice nod to some of
the more famous Hellblazer stories.
Her name is Zed, she’s a comic book character
and will be in all the episodes going forward.
She’s the new female lead.
The Liv character probably isn’t coming
back.
I know it sounds weird, but it would have
been too expensive for them to reshoot the
pilot.
I’m a huge fan of Lucy Griffiths but all
of the changes they made to the show are for
the better.
You guys will totally dig the Zed character.
She’s being played by Anjelica Celaya.
They even brought her to Comic Con this summer.
What they are keeping is Jasper Winter’s
Tower and the scryers map Liv made.
That will be the device that they use to travel
from mystery to mystery as they help people
and try to figure out what Nergal is trying
to do on earth.
The tower itself works a lot like the Tower
of Fate, but it’s not the Tower of Fate.
Even though they had the helmet of fate in
there.
And I know a lot of you were asking me whether
the skull in the glass case meant Pandora
would be coming on the show.
At comic con David Goyer said that the show
had free reign in the mystical corner of the
DC Universe, so potentially they could do
a version of Justice League Dark at some point.
They can do any of the mystical characters
they want.
So everyone is up for grabs.
But don’t expect Doctor Fate, That would
be like bringing Superman on Arrow.
Speaking of supporting characters.
Number 3 - Team Constantine
So right now here’s who the good guys are
going to be.
John Constantine of course, Chaz and Zed from
the comics and Manny the Angel.
He’s not from the comics but Constantine
has worked with angels in the past.
If you picked up the antagonistic vibe from
Constantine when Manny started poking in his
business it’s because he generally holds
all of heaven and all of hell in contempt.
He hates everyone, but like Manny teased,
if he can help Heaven stop whatever Nergal
is planning, it might redeem his soul.
They damned him to hell when Astra’s soul
was taken by Nergal.
As for potential other characters this season,
they’ll probably start making more announcements
once the show gets picked up for a full season.
We probably won’t learn about that for a
couple weeks.
But because Warner Brothers wants to flex
it’s tv muscles as much as possible, I think
the odds the show will be safe from cancellation
are pretty good.
The other supporting characters in the episode
weren’t necessarily allies but I’ll explain
them when I do more easter eggs in a sec.
Number 2 - The Demon Nergal
They teased him as the big bad but he’s
the biggest villain Constantine has dealt
with on a regular basis in the comics.
He really only started dealing with Satan
directly during the Dangerous Habits Storyline.
That’s also the comic that deals with him
having terminal cancer.
The show isn’t doing this, mostly because
he can’t smoke on tv.
The lighter that he keeps flipping during
the episode is a reference to that.
I don’t think Satan will be a notable character
on the show this season, I think Nergal will
be the biggest villain we meet.
Number 1 - Dark Constantine
In the comics Constantine had to face an evil
future version of himself and there was even
a brief period when he was forced to let Nergal
possess his body.
On the show this big scene at the end was
one of the things they changed from the original
pilot.
I guess just because they thought it worked
better thematically than having a random demon.
I did see the original pilot and I have to
agree that Dark Constantine is way better.
Expect the show to use him again as a villain
device.
It just seems like too much fun to have your
hero fighting an evil future version of himself.
It’s almost like the Flash with Professor
Zoom being a future twisted version of a speedster.
Let me know what your favorite moment was,
and while you think about it.
Here’s all the other easter eggs I spotted:
So I already mentioned the Helmet of Fate,
but Jasper Winters on the show might be Baron
Winters.
In the comics he was the host for all souls
not claimed by Heaven or Hell.
So he went mad from it all.
But he did live in an alternate dimension,
so you could think of the tower they’re
using as their home base as that place.
Here’s the Ibistick, it’s a magical wand
that can be used for acts of good.
It works a little like the helmet of fate
in that when someone uses it it bonds with
them.
But it doesn’t work against black magic
which is an interesting twist.
Ibis is connected to the Shazam family, but
since the movies are doing Shazam and Black
Adam.
I don’t expect them to appear on the show.
Then there’s Pandora’s Box, this is the
skull of Pandora, the biblical pandora who
unleashed all evil into the world.
The Doctor John meets with here, Doctor Huntoon
also worked at Arkham Asylum.
In the comics he also ended up trying to hurt
constantine for wrecking his personal life.
If the show doesn’t go back to Ravenscar
then I don’t expect that character to come
back very often.
Ritchie Simpson in the comics ended up becoming
a techno demon.
I don’t know if they’ll keep using his
character, but these toy robots on his desk
are a big wink at his future.
Ivy University where he works is also the
same place in the comics where the Ray Palmer
Atom was a professor, it’s also the place
where the Ronnie Raymond Firestorm was a student.
Both Arrow and the Flash are doing those characters,
so it’s a nice link up with those shows.
The backwards writing on the wall here might
be an easter egg for Zatanna or Zatarra.
Both characters have been on TV before so
Constantine could totally bring them on too
at some point.
Let me know if you spotted any other references
I didn’t mention.
And to answer the big crossover question.
Yes, Constantine does exist inside the shared
DC TV show universe.
But because it’s a different network, don’t
expect to see stephen amell or grant gustin
cameo any time soon.
But yes, they are connected.
Overall I gave the episode a solid B. Generally
I don’t get as excited for Pilot episodes
as I do for the regular series.
Pilots are designed to jam everything and
the kitchen sink into a 42 minute window.
Normal episodes keep things much simpler so
you get to spend more time developing a few
characters versus many.
So just in general, expect the show to be
a lot more fun once as we see more and more
new episodes.
New shows in general always have a really
easy time getting better.
It always takes a while to figure out the
characters from a writing standpoint.
I am a fan of Matt Ryan’s very British Constantine,
I’m so glad the show got that right.
Harold Perrineau is great and I love his stuff
so I’m interested to see more of Manny.
He didn’t have a lot of time in the pilot
so it’s hard to get a sense of his character.
The same is true of Charles Halford as Chas.
Another huge character from the comics, so
I’m excited to watch the actor develop him.
Zed we haven’t really seen yet, so I can’t
say much about her.
She’ll be in next week’s episode.
In general the story was great, I didn’t
mind the minor changes to his backstory.
As long as they throw us a swamp thing bone
every once and a while.
I’ll post my episode 2 review after next
week’s episode airs.
I won’t be doing a q&a for this just because
I’m already doing a bunch of videos tomorrow.
But I’ll try to answer as many questions
as possible in the comments.
Right now click here to learn more about my
favorite Constantine Comic Stories and Click
here for this week’s Arrow.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you guys tomorrow!